sehr geehrte damen und herren ich gebe
die anzahl der abgegebenen stimmen
bekannt abgegebene stimmzettel 90
gültige stimmzettel 90 enthaltungen eine
auf den wahlvorschlag der fraktion die
linke der spd bündnis 90/die grünen
drucksache 7 strich 204 für abgeordnete
bodo ramelow stimmten 44 stimmen
wahlvorschlag der fraktion der afg in
drucksache 7 strich 240er christoph
kindervater 0 stimmen wahlvorschlag der
fraktion der fdp drucksache 7 sprich 242
abgeordneter thomas kemmerich 45 ja
stimmen
[Applaus]
damit haben wir das ergebnis das man
merkt das auch ist griechen war kern
abgeordneten kemmerich nehmen sie die
wahl zum ministerpräsidenten an
dann darf ich ihnen gratulieren
einen neuen ministerpräsidenten es ist
der parteichef der fdp thomas permanent
das hat hier in so viele überrascht mich
schließlich den tagesordnungspunkt 1
rufe auf den tagesordnungspunkt 2 die
vereidigung des ministerpräsidenten des
freistaates thomas kemmerich wird jetzt
irgendwie so agenten zu seiner verein in
klar vorn
die anwesenden bitte ich sich von ihren
plätzen man merkt so erheben dass er da
offenbar doch überrascht ist mit diesem
ergebnis hat wohl auch thomas kemmerich
am ende doch nicht gerechnet
das ist eine faustdicke überraschung das
muss man so deutlich sagen wir haben
über diesen fall spekuliert jetzt ist er
tatsächlich eingetreten
vereidigung des ministerpräsidenten des
freistaats thüringen sehr geehrter herr
ministerpräsident thomas kemmerich
verlesen nun die in artikel 71 der
verfassung des freistaats thüringen
vorgeschriebene eidesformel und bitte
sie diese eidesformel nach zu sprechen
sie können den eid anschließend mit den
worten so wahr mir gott helfe
bekräftigen die eidesformel lautete ich
schwöre ich schwöre dass ich meine kraft
dem wohle des volkes widmen dass ich
meine kraft dem wohle des volkes widmen
verfassung und gesetze waren verfassung
und gesetze waren meine pflichten
gewissenhaft erfüllen meine pflichten
gewissenhaft erfüllen und gerechtigkeit
gegen jedermann üben werde und
gerechtigkeit gegen jedermann üben werde
so wahr mir gott helfe
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte damen und herren ich
schließe diesen tagesordnungspunkt 2 ab
mike mohring cdu fraktionschef
gratuliert thomas kemmerich
der mann muss um einmal sagen uns der
fdp ist fdp-politiker eine partei die
bei der landtagswahl mit ach und krach
in den landtag gekommen ist ist da im
laufe des abends damals mehrfach so aus
als hätten die es eigentlich nicht
angeschafft
wir haben uns auch gerade gesehen dass
der fraktionsvorsitzende afd
herr hüppe gratuliert hat und auch wenn
die wahl geheim ist an dieser stelle
kann man denkt ich soweit spekulieren
die afg hat ihn ins amt gehoben denn es
gab tatsächlich 0 stimmen für den
kandidaten der afg selbst das heißt die
ard hat geschlossen gestimmt und zwar
nicht für ihren eigenen kandidaten in
der tat noch mal zur verdeutlichung
während jetzt hier die abgeordneten dem
neu gewählten ministerpräsidenten das
ist gelebte tradition in allen
bundesländern gratuliert die zahlen zur
verdeutlichung der afg kandidat
kindervater hat im letzten wahlgang
keiner stimme bekommen
es gab eine enthaltung bodo ramelow von
der linkspartei bekommt 44 wie schon im
zweiten wahlgang das heißt es ist keiner
weiter in das lager von rot-rot-grün
rüber gewechselt und thomas kemmerich
gewinnt mit einer stimme mehrheit mit 45
stimmen diese wahl